Okay, so we're going to have a last quiz for this section,
and it's going to be a fairly challenging one.
So we'll give it a gold star.
Your goal here is to define a procedure, "biggest",
that takes 3 inputs that are all numbers
and it outputs the greatest of the 3 numbers.
So here's a few examples:
So if the 3 inputs are "6", "2", and "3" the output of "biggest" should be "6".
If the 3 inputs are "6", "2", and "7", then the output of "biggest" should be "7".
And if the 3 inputs are "6", "9", and "3", the output should be "9".
So whichever of the 3 inputs is the greatest number,
is the output that your procedure should produce, and it should return that.
So I've shown the outputs.
We wouldn't actually see them, unless we printed them out.